imaginez un coeur de ville où le citoyen
retrouve l envie de flâner et de faire
les boutiques dans un environnement non
polluée où l'humain retrouverait quitte
sa place
rien ne serait plus comme avant parce
que ses habitants voudraient désormais
qu'on les écoute qu'on les entend cette
ville où l'espoir n'est plus une utopie
sévèrement
dans les années 50
ils ont été la capitale du machinisme
agricole avec casp aucun qui ont
travaillé dans l'hyper cette cité
ouvrière elle comptait aussi une
cinquantaine d'entreprises dans la
confection et la porcelaine et puis au
début des années 80 qui dégringole les
usines ferment les unes après les autres
un tiers des emplois va disparaître le
problème ici c'est effectivement en
attendant ont conscience et
responsabilité des élus les choix
économiques vont coûter cher très cher à
vierzon comme ce projet de plateforme
multimodale dangereux inondables qui a
coûté plusieurs millions d'euros pour
rien les conséquences sont dramatiques
la ville passe de 35000 à 28 milles
habitants et plus d'une cinquantaine de
commerces ont fermé eu d'emplois
moindres gras d'achat et parmi les
ouvriers étrangers qui représentait 60
pour cent de la main d'oeuvre
les portugais en a payé le prix et des
anciens se souvient de cette époque
française contre le portugal maintenant
je vais connu des problèmes de chômage
de 6 bourges en dessous l'ancien
instituteur native de vierzon qui exerça
trois mandats consécutifs de mer entre
1990 et 2008 le problème de cette ville
c'est qu'elle n'a pas réussi à se
réunifier hier dont c'était quatre
communes jusqu'en 1930 jusqu'en 1937 et
la guerre à un coupé l'élan de la fusion
des quatre garçons et on est encore à la
recherche du centre-ville
pourtant depuis 2008 la nouvelle équipe
municipale semble avoir compris que pour
réunifier vierzon il fallait repenser
son centre ville et convaincre les
propriétaires de céder leur immeuble
vétuste pour les réhabiliter
on fait des opérations comme celle ci où
à la sem rachète les locaux l'armée à
niveau et renault à des commerçants dans
des locaux mieux adaptés au commerce
d'aujourd'hui on l'a vu entre le
résultat il ya plusieurs commerces qui
ont rouvert d'entre eux est aujourd'hui
une dynamique entre un secret dans la
rue la république et on transpire à
permettre notamment votre secteur power
et des blogueurs mais depuis la crise de
la situation ici ne sait pas en danger
bien au contraire et c'est au secours
populaire qu'on peut en mesurer
l'ampleur plus de 2700 bénéficiaire l'an
dernier soit 10 % de la population avec
une majorité de retraités et de jeunes
sans emploi bon bah je pense qu'il ya
des choses à préparer pour un camion
jamais non camion est parti dès sa
première foire commence à regrouper les
actions
de plus en plus de demandes notamment en
fait conscient des produits alimentaires
mais aussi les aides au logement qui
peut envoyer les énergies que ça le free
nous avons conduit malheureusement à
coluche limité en nombre ce job parce
que la bible personnelle à ben arfa saha
moins de travail c'est moins d'argent à
dépenser dans le commerce local qui a
fini par péricliter 7 rue du centre
ville particulièrement animé il ya 30
ans a perdu les trois quarts de ces
commerçants qui ont dû mettre la clé
sous la porte comme cette femme qui
n'arrivait plus à régler un loyer
particulièrement élevé aujourd'hui on la
retrouve sur les marchés et si elle
n'est pas désespérée elle voudrait
croire un électrochoc des gens qui ont
de l'argent dépensé travail
il n'y a pas de travail dans la ville
les gens ce qui reste c'est parce qu'ils
n'ont pas le choix si les vierzonnais le
croient plus de miracles leur
préoccupation reste l'insécurité ou
plutôt le sentiment qu'ils en sécurité à
vierzon qu'ailleurs mais là des
quartiers qui sont plus sensibles aussi
les gens se sentent un petit peu on sent
de la sécurité parce que on voit
beaucoup de gens qui se promènent qui
traînent les gens pas peur mais son
avion une préoccupation que comprend le
maire actuel un peu fataliste tout en
essayant de rassurer
le forum c'est un des sujets qu'on a
traitées avec la préfecture puisque les
caméras de vidéosurveillance ont mises
en place
donc on a traité avec des patrouilles
d'une équipe de médiation voilà on sait
très bien que c'est un sujet important
parce que c'est là où se concentrent les
difficultés on espère le traiter comme
ça aujourd'hui il ya quand même moins de
difficultés qu'il ya quelques mois et je
pense que ça va s'arranger
petit à petit mais mais il n'y a pas de
secret si on ne crée pas d'emplois et
s'il n'y a pas de boulot pour les gens
on va toujours avoir ces problèmes qui
vont perdurer le centre-ville au
diapason à 23 heures mais lui sous les
airs d'un tout à fait car on y rencontre
des petits groupes de jeunes qui suis à
l'origine de la psychose qui s'est
emparée de la population depuis un an
ils ont quitté la région parisienne dans
l'espoir de trouver un emploi et des
loyers moins chers française nous sommes
nés français donc de discrimination peu
importe peu importe qui gerba les
habitants ils disent que vous faites
beaucoup de bruit que vous faites du
trafic de shit concept en colocation
console comme on peut
ces palois au café qu'on a trouvé
bon nous ta nous n en sommes habitués on
se démerde
il ya des contrats et des années contre
à bord des deux formations
bon c'est le trafic n'est pas affectée
taux montre à pékin une fois par semaine
daniel et judicaël viennent à vierzon
rencontrer des jeunes désoeuvrés qui se
retrouve dans certains quartiers ils
font partie de l'équipe de prévention
est inhérente leur mission entretenir le
dialogue avec les 15 25 ans jacques
boulot c'est de vous rencontrer que
discuter avait loué un petit peu le
contre phrase quand votre but de vue
revanche que vous faites
car s'en vont changer vos centres
d'intérêts si vous intéresse qui vous en
kit il
voilà est ce que la critique et qui
savent que quand on consomme de l'alcool
à paris ça consomme une fois ou deux
fois
pourtant beaucoup beaucoup d'alcool ça
peut dégénérer vers une situation très
dangereuse et encore nourrir notre
travail consiste à essentiellement à
sensibiliser les jeunes sur la
dangerosité des produits dans un premier
temps effectivement on peut rencontrer
des jeunes qui vont goûter l'alcool un
goûter du cannabis de façon festive
là on travaille sur ce qu'on appelle la
responsabilisation si on leur dit si
vous tes ces produits là vous êtes un
petit peu bien un peu éméché jette un
petit os x est heureux et après bien
évidemment on aborde le sujet de cas je
consomme
je consomme un peu produits mettez ce
qui arrive si je continue à consommer de
plus en plus on leur explique qu'ils
tactique de 4h à ces images et elle
coïnciderait dépendance et les
conséquences graves que ça peut amener
voilà surtout pour les jeunes en 4e par
l'anc troisième qui le concerne à peu
cannabis que ne forme pas content du
tout de la dangereuse dangerosité du
produit lorsque vous avoue consommer un
peu de cannabis
comme sa modération que ce que je veux
dire pas avec modération
c'est à dire de temps en temps je n'y
suis un peu ras vue de discuter parce
que le fait déjà on n'est pas leur
parole on est des personnes je dire
entre guillemets à nonu et puisse de
façon formelle on leur demande pas leurs
mots leurs prénoms
il n'y a pas que ça du coup il faut
voilà à l'aise dans le change on n'a pas
un discours moralisateur et ça fait que
ça très bénéfique l'habitude on ne peut
pas on se connaît tous en fête et fait
des fois c'est chiant je te tuer je
connais leurs amis voilà comme mobile
possible et aussi est-ce que vous n'êtes
pas aussi acteur aussi au sein de votre
territoire aussi porté par exemple des
projets jeudi un moment donné proposer
quelque chose
après la ville honnêtement je remercie
les mots la réduire en vivent
honnêtement faire bouger la ville en
interpellant des élus c'est l'objectif
que se sont donnée antoine et anthony en
prenant la tête de l'union commerciale
pour eux c'est aussi aux citoyens de
faire des propositions de monsieur
dumont en l'occurrence nous a dit qu'il
ne suivrait qui ce prêt à nous aider
pour des animations même à essayer de
débloquer des fonds supplémentaires au
essayer quand ils repartent avec une
cantine donne envie de se promener avec
des belles rues pavées des très beaux
patrimoines des immeubles et poutres
apparentes revenons à moi en tout cas ça
me plaît j'aime regarder ça en est où
est le problème c'est que personne ne
découvre
antoine et anthony ne sont plus les
seuls à vouloir faire bouger les choses
une association de citoyens s'est
constitué spontanément pour peser sur
les futurs décision que doit prendre la
municipalité et en particulier la
revitalisation du centre historique a
relevé aux citoyens mais je n'ai su
savoir votre avis ça fait pas que les
pétoches la démocratie elle doit être à
double sens là le sens montant
c'est à dire nous qui allons voter par
ailleurs hockey et une fois que
l'ascenseur de l'élection est arrivé le
problème c'est qu'elle ne redescend pas
donc nous qu'on aimerait c'est qu'elle
redescende et que les élus se remettent
à notre niveau pour simplement nous
demander ce qu'on aimerait pour cette
ville
ce que c'est quand même nous qui
habitons cette ville c'est nous qui
payons nos impôts pour ce camp paye que
leurs chances d'en payer c'est nous qui
habitons c'est nous qui marchons sur les
trottoirs c'est nous qui tous les jours
on est dans la rue et un moment donné on
se dit stop il faut qu'on soit entendu
pas écouté faut qu'on soit entendu les
vierzonnais ont subi un électrochoc en
milieu en 1968 faut le dire quand
jacques brel a sorti sa chanson si vous
faites le tour si vous l'avez vous là où
fleurs ce n'est pas partout la cas d
argent ou les vierzonnais pense que ces
photographes de cette chanson quelque
part a rendu célèbre concrètement ces
facteurs les tracts en haut-languedoc
la semaine dernière le week-end dernier
j'étais en belgique dans le pays
s'appelle signer le démangeait un
restaurant et on a discuté avec le
comprendre d'où vous venez d'où je
débarque bientôt à les faire
il ya une désaffection des 100 produits
d'un petit peu partout et la politique
actuelle c'est en général de s'occuper
des banlieues qui pose problème mais
dorénavant la plupart des centres villes
pose des problèmes et il faut absolument
s'attaquer à cela quelques parcours pas
très fier si depuis deux ans en effet la
priorité a été donnée aux quartiers
sensibles qui est lui du clos du roy
toujours en quête de reconnaissance et
celui de bellevue les quartiers nous on
a voulu remplacer la plupart des
immeubles par des logements
pavillonnaires pour une population issue
de l'immigration des années 60 80 qui
vivent avec moins d'un smic
seul le quartier celhay été totalement
repensée cette ancienne barre hlm par
exemple a été remplacées par des
commerces de proximité et de coquettes
maisons dans un environnement plutôt
agréable ici la population n'a pas
changé ses habitudes le marché populaire
du mardi à garder cette clientèle
cosmopolite
c'est toujours plus facile à vivre
donc on est mieux maintenant contraire
ça crame bien changé on a été gâté si
tout est rénové je pense que ces raids m
le centre commercial la locomotive du
quartier jeudi de nouveaux quartiers
quoi dernier quartier en voie de
réhabilitation celui du colombier là
aussi les tours des années 60 ont été
démolis au profit de cavillon en
accession à la propriété avec des loyers
qui n'ont pas augmenté pour autant
ici c'était un champ s'il ya quatre ans
à peu près et c'est la première
opération de paix rue ce qu'on appelle
hors site c'est à dire que c'était pas
sur des logements qui ont été démolis
on a récupéré un champ entier et on
s'est dit c'est super bien placé il à
l'école à côté il ya le complexe de foot
on n'est pas très loin son premier donc
on a mis le 17 premiers pavillons avec
le fisc vivo l'habitat dans le cadre du
programme de rénovation urbaine
or si tu es aujourd'hui c'est un
quartier qui merveilleusement bien situé
c'est une salle qui permet à tout un
chacun dans ce quartier de faire unique
a été refaite dans le cadre du père
huées et pour nous aucun moment que les
petits puissent venir une fois qu'ils
ont fait leurs devoirs ou se faire aider
par l'association pour faire leurs
devoirs d'ailleurs le renouveau de
vierzon s'il se concrétise passera aussi
et surtout par la métamorphose son lycée
professionnel fleuron national et fierté
locale
henri brisson il a formé plus de quinze
sont jeunes aux métiers de l'industrie
dans les années 80 c'est pourquoi la
région a décidé d'y investir 3 millions
d'euros
la formation unique en région centre
écrit actuellement est la seule filière
complète affaires régionales qui eux
disposent éducation nationale vient donc
là on situe dans l'atelier fondre et du
lycée henri-brisson cet atelier va être
entièrement rénové dans les deux ans qui
arrive pour que nos formations s'adapte
à la réalité des métiers et monfreid
définitivement que l'an fonderie au
21ème siècle
ça n'est plus la fonderie du 19ème et
germinal lâche andré henri bresson et la
fonderie qui va être la première de
toute la région grand ouest et qui va
donc pouvoir fournir des techniciens et
des étudiants à la pointe des métiers de
demain
dans ce domaine là
un optimisme que vous pourrez partager
si l'on en croit la création d'une
plateforme multimodale de ferroutage sur
ces zones industrielles qui pourrait
attirer de nouvelles d'activité à
l'exemple de cette fonderie en plein
essor qui emploie 60 salariés et créer
un partenariat avec le lycée en douceur
notre responsable de service sur fusion
temps des gens et ce malgré des gens qui
ont plus l hôpital
c'est là qu'il en était opera 10 est
également recruté entre cadors de
l'école donc on a toujours très bonnes
relations
la bonne nouvelle pour la ville c'est le
nouveau pm le plan de rénovation urbaine
de 35 millions d'euros dont elle doit
bénéficier et qui va lui permettre de
prendre un nouveau départ
alors ça consiste à réaménager
complètement la rue de la république
complètement l'îlot brunet rollinat en
cassant cet immeuble jaune en remettant
en état les meubles les nouvelles
galeries de la fin du 19e et donc de
refaire une espèce de petit giratoire
autour de cet îlot qui sera réhabilité
pour amener aussi du commerce et
peut-être sans doute un marché couvert
c'est ça l'objectif
avec du logement au dessus et puis
refaire complètement les places qui nous
mène notamment à l'eau et refaire la rue
maréchal joffre
andrade rue pour à la fois du logement
et peut-être des ateliers d'art parce
que c'est ça la vocation de la rue
maréchal joffre pérusse et 35 à 40
millions d'euros qui sont payés par
l'état et la région quasiment pour
moitié par les bailleurs sociaux pour 40
% et par la ville et le conseil général
pour le reste voilà c'est un projet qui
devrait cette année de 2015 à 2020 de
migrants
s'il est vierge mais parviennent pour se
mettre d'accord autour d'un projet qui
met régnard enfin alors la chance sous
le bras elle deviendra l'hymne d'une
ville qui a décidé de rebondir
il